[Music]
we're learning how a murder shown in a
48 hours episode from 2015 could help
police in a current investigation
last saturday 48 hours profiled the
death of amy harwick a therapist who at
one time was engaged to drew carey the
host of the price is right on cbs
harwick was found unresponsive below her
balcony two years ago after someone had
strength strangled her gareth pursehouse
an ex-boyfriend is being held for trial
in harwick's death he has pleaded not
guilty harwick had told police that
purse house had previously assaulted her
and she had two restraining orders
against him the police found a syringe
like this on the balcony filled with
liquid harwick didn't smoke or do drugs
when lab tests detected nicotine in the
syringe one investigator on the case
immediately recognized it as lethal
poison because of a 48 hours episode he
watched back in 2015.
it featured jeopardy winner paul curry
using a deadly injection of nicotine to
kill his wife vlad duties spoke with 48
hours correspondent erin moriarty about
this development
amy harwick's autopsy did not check for
nicotine
and so
one of the reasons why this matters is
because other investigators need to know
that nicotine in a liquid form can be
used as a weapon if these investigators
had not seen
the curry case
and not seen it on 48 hours they might
not have realized the value of that
syringe as evidence at least to show
intent
if prosecutors can link purse house to
that syringe they may be able to use it
as evidence against him